all right we turned out of the
Washington swamp where Joe Biden is
quote-confident that a deal will be
reached on the debt ceiling so we don't
default as a country so we're just two
weeks to go is Mr my way or the highway
Joe Biden finally negotiating or is it
too little too late here with more house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy is with us Mr
speaker thank you
you know thank you sir I
over a hundred days ago I started
reaching out to you and saying Mr
Speaker any update on the debt ceiling
Mr Speaker any update you had that one
meeting 104 days ago uh and Joe Biden
said he would not negotiate you reached
out to him almost daily if I'm not
mistaken so you knew the debt ceiling
deadline was coming you passed a really
responsible Bill tell me how the
negotiations are going and do you think
your caucus is willing to give up a
really good bill in exchange for Joe
Biden betting that you'd never get that
bill passed
well first of all Sean thank you for
your help and thank you to all the
viewers and especially to all the
Republican members in the house and in
the Senate because they have heard held
firm together you were right on February
1st I sat down with the president saying
let's negotiate a debt ceiling increase
but also change the trajectory of the
money that we're spending we got to stop
just just run away spending and he
ignored us for a hundred and five days
but because we united we were able to
pass a bill we got into where we had a
meeting the president said all along he
would not negotiate and you'd had to
just increase the debt silly he and
Chuck Schumer said that yesterday was a
breakthrough they acknowledged that it's
no longer a position they can hold and
now they've appointed two of their
administrative people to work with our
staff to work to try to find and solve
this problem but you know we've been
very clear Sean
um you can't keep raising the debt so
it's like having your child have a
credit card in year after year after
year you keep reaching the limit and you
just keep expanding it expanding it well
there comes a point where your credit
card now costs you more than all the
money you make in a year bigger than
your entire economy you're responsible
for paying it but shouldn't you actually
look how you're spending money so a
limit save grow we limit how much we
spend in the future we save money by
pulling back that coven money that
wasn't spent we put in work requirements
this is only for able-bodied people with
no dependents it helps them take them
from poverty to jobs helps them get out
of that poverty mess and then we look at
places that we could cut the red tape so
we could build things that America get
we become energy independent that's just
a few of the things we've also shown
remember what we put in here cutting
those 87 000 IRS agents a lot of good
ideas to be able to raise the debt
ceiling but actually put an economy
that's stronger less dependent on China
Mr Speaker you were able you were able
to pass this by a margin of only two
votes you don't have have that big a
margin to play with in the house so you
only have 14 days to go and I think the
budget is really responsible you raise
the debts healing you bring spending
back to 2022 levels you reduce Baseline
budgeting increases to what one percent
a year uh the CBO scores it out at 4.8
trillion saved over 10 years that to me
is fiscal responsibility and all the
other things that you mentioned now
let's say that Biden says this is my
final offer and you bring that deal back
to your caucus you think you're going to
get a majority in your caucus to go
along with this late minute deal after
he wouldn't even talk to you for 100
days
Sean I believe we can if we come to a
good agreement because think of this
we the president said he wasn't going to
negotiate we were just going to raise
the debt ceiling first of all we have
just now been able to have a victory the
president could no longer say that so no
the debt ceiling will not get raised
with no changes if we get a fundamental
change where we get a cap in what we're
spending that's trillions of dollars
saving if we change the directory where
we get work requirements that's the
biggest welfare reform we've had since
Bill Clinton signed the bill if we're
able to get savings where we're spending
less that will be the biggest cut since
Ronald Reagan this is an idea that
Republicans have stuck together in the
house and the Senate we're going to have
to realize when we can declare Victory
and show the American public when we
stick together we can win and make
America stronger all right I think in
large part and I got to give credit to
your colleagues in the Senate they have
stood by you and your bill and said no
it'll be speaker McCarthy and Joe Biden
that negotiate this you have 43 Senators
that signed a document saying they'd
stick by your bill uh John Kennedy
didn't sign it but he said he would
stick by your bill so that's really 4
34. so it's not going to happen they're
not going to get a bill out of the
Senate no basically it's going to be
your bill and any changes you might make
where might you think about making
changes to what I think was a really
good bill that that you passed in the
house
look Sean that was a really good bill in
the house we have to pass the house and
the Senate we're sitting with the
president now we told them we have to
spend less we told them we're going to
negotiate only off our bill and so we're
sitting in the room trying to get this
done where we can get this done to be
able to move forward to stop our
inflation get us off the dependency of
China and get America working again we
combine that together Republicans have
shown that we can lead just like on the
border the president ignored this
problem he ignored the Border but no we
also passed hr2 secure our border and
we're looking to places that could we
put something of that in this bill as
well and by the way inflation is
transitory
um I will say this Mr Speaker I
appreciate the fact that you're at this
late hour willing to negotiate with them
after he abandoned you and the entire
Republican majority in the house uh
however I will say that if there is a
default for the first time in the
history of this country that will be on
Biden that will be Biden's default it
will be his hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else